We are here with the incomparable Marie Osmond.
And I happened to be with your brother,
and it's funny, 'cause we talked about some deep stuff.
Really? He's not that deep.
(Drew laughing)
Well, that's going to lead perfectly into our game,
Donny versus Marie.
And we asked him some questions.
And now we're going to ask you in a game we're calling,
Donny versus Marie.
(upbeat music)
Oh, no.
(audience clapping)
All right.
Okay, here's how it works.
I'm going to ask you a question
and after you answer, we'll see what Donny said.
And if you can match three out of five of Donny's answers,
you win.
And if you win,
Donny said, he'll go on his Instagram
and sing "Paper Roses," your iconic hit song.
But if you lose,
apparently you have agreed to go on your Instagram
and sing "Puppy Love," his iconic song.
(Marie laughing)
Okay.
This is making it nerve wracking and more exciting.
In other words, I have to win.
Okay. Gotcha.
Okay. Here we go.
Number one,
who is more likely to forget the lyrics to a song?
Me.
Here's what Donny said.
So Marie is going to say it's me,
but it's Marie.
(bell ringing)
Okay.
No, it's me. It's definitely me.
All right.
Who doesn't mind re-wearing costumes without being cleaned?
He would probably say me.
All right. Donny's answer was.
That's definitely me.
(buzzer buzzing)
Yeah, it's him.
He's right. It is him.
Okay.
I got that one wrong. Okay.
We're one for one here. All right.
Who is likely to eat food after it fell on the floor?
Donny.
(audience laughing)
And Donny's response was.
Oh, that's definitely Marie.
(buzzer buzzing)
She has the three second rule.
Actually, she pushes it to 10 seconds.
I thought this is where we could bond,
'cause I have the same rule.
He's kind of weird.
Yeah that's okay, I'll give him that one.
Okay.
Who was the favorite growing up?
Donny.
And Donny's response was.
Me.
Marie is going to say it was her, but it was me.
All right, you get that one.
(audience clapping)
We're two to two.
Okay.
I'm just going by what I know his brain would say.
It was me.
All right. Well, this is the tie breaker.
Who is more likely to keep a secret?
Well, it's me, but he'll say it's him.
Well, here's what Donny said.
Me,
because I told her I was the peacock
on "The Masked Singer,"
He's so full of crap.
And she let it out.
(Drew laughing)
Is that true?
Did yo tell people he was "The Masked Singer?"
So, he told me because he was flying in and out.
And then I was doing some press,
I can't remember what project I was doing,
and their network people,
they said, "oh yeah how about that?
You know, Donny is the peacock."
They set me up and I went, "oh, I guess they told him
because it's the network."
And I said, "oh yeah, right."
And then I realized they'd set me up
and then I tried to get out of it.
Oh, he was so mad.
Oh my gosh, he was so mad. (laughing)
I love that that was the answer.
We all jumped for joy when Donny was doing that.
So what does this mean?
This means he's singing "Paper Roses," right?
It means he is singing "Paper Roses," Marie.
Okay, I'm watching.
All right.
And then I'll give you my response on my social media.
And that means you win.
Marie's newest album "Unexpected" is out now.
And also her latest special "An Evening With Marie"
on BYU TV is out.
Please enjoy it.
Thank you so much, Marie.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)